Hello, everyone.
Welcome to act in flat
guest stream number 19.1.
It's March 25th 2022.
And we are here with Marco fucken
and we are going to be discussing
the recent paper.
Extended predictive minds
do mark up blankets matter
so if you're watching live,
please feel free to put
comments or questions in the live chat
and hopefully we can address them.
And Marco, really appreciate you joining.
Looking forward to hearing about this
paper and your lines of research show
would be awesome to hear an introduction
and take it away.
Okay. Hi everyone.
So I'm not a.
I actually I'm a PhD candidate initially
and deep deeper basically.
Is an attempt to understand
what was going on
in the active inference literature
with the external listening
journalism debate
from a philosophical perspective.
So why study philosophy?
For the most part,
I'm not super mathematical savvy
and I have basically a background
in embodied extended cognition
and I stumbled upon the the papers
by who year onset and other
and I wanted to understand
what was going on
with the d-mark of blanket tool.
And so I wrote a paper about it
due to understand what was going on
and to try to suggest that maybe
that much emphasis on Markov
Blanket is a bit misplaced.
And yes,
that's it for a general introduction
or any deeper, I think.
And then Europe
for any question or any doubt anything.
OK, cool.
So maybe I'll just ask some questions
and we'll just see where it goes.
For somebody who was unfamiliar
with extended cognitive processes
or the state of the art,
maybe outside of active inference,
just what is this area?
How are people looking at it outside
of the active inference, fip, angle
and like what is the contemporary state
of that area?
So OK, so the extended cognition stuff
say your fishery is something that
spawned out of pepper by and Chalmers
in the early 2000 physically
and their original idea was
as I understand it
at least is this that sometimes at least
you interact with the environment
in a way
such that part of cognition happens
in the environment itself.
So my go to example
is using pen and paper to do math.
When you use pen and paper to do math,
you write down partial results
and that's from a paper is working
as a piece of your working memory is just
that is not inside
your brain is around you on your desk
or whenever you are doing math.
And so that was basically
the original idea.
And from that
there has been a rich collaboration
with people
like Richard Minnery suggesting that's
actually good.
We should think of extended
cognitive processes
as processes that transform
our cognitive capacities
is not just
more stuff, more memory, more symbols,
but new stuff,
new capacities, new symbols, new
cognitive processes that take place
in the interaction in between the subject
and the environment.
So we have that line of research
and then you have a more see
and active line of research
that tends to stress the idea.
That's basically
all cognition takes place in the world,
interacting with affordances
or interacting with
your surrounding environments.
But I'm not super expert
on that line of research,
and you extended
mine are a bit more conservative.
Yeah.
So did
punch line would be this that sometimes
stuff in the external world
really is mostly process
possible, a cog of the machinery
that does your thinking
that is the
clearest and most forceful way
in which I'm able
to do booted off the extended mind.
And of course, sorry, once
you have these ideas on the table,
the question is OK,
but where, when versus it's stuff
is then in, deeper is in.
But I don't know
are our cell phones in our
all books in your at my left
you might not be able to see it
but there is the library
with a lot of books I read.
Are all those books part of my memory?
Probably not.
But you need some sort of boundary
and vestigial form of block of course.
So leave it like this.
Well, I like this
how you said it was like a cog
and it's kind of like cognition.
So it's right there in word, even though
that's a little bit of a wordplay
and also very interesting
about the more difference.
Like we're not just augmenting
the computer with a bigger hard drive
or more ram. It truly can be difference.
And so I think maybe
we could return to this idea of like,
what is the space of the adjacent
possible for cognitive systems,
especially if they compose
in these nonlinear ways?
But could you maybe
walk us through
some of the pieces of the paper?
Like what
brought you to the introduction?
What brought you to writing this paper
on markup?
Like it's and then what did you sort of
weave together in the introduction?
How did you clash them in the middle?
And then
where did you leave us at the end?
So did you walk through to the paper
as something
not separate from being able
to do satisfactory at least?
So first step
was to what motivated me.
It was to try and figure out
what was going on between Andy
Clark Yakub, who we Ramstad
and Mark of Black.
So cause and what I wanted to argue
basically
was something like this
that even if you set aside
you works by remembering a book
and others or men are in the alerts that
tend to give you
this sort of message
like we have a perfectly fine
mathematical concept of markup blankets
and then a strange concept of reason
blankets that is a big mathematical
and a bit too logical
and you're not really sure what it is,
even if you live this sort of war
inside the
what I wanted to say is that he way in
which mock of blankets are used
for when it comes
to discussing the extent of mind stuff
that is very limited
to the specific application.
But for the extended mind,
the usage of markup blankets
is not really useful,
doesn't mean nothing of particular volume
and tends to give a big headache
to people that are not into acting.
And so I would recommend not using them
as the main arguments
I think there is no main artifact of
I think I have three arguments
that are well, first
in order to find the markup blankets,
it seems that
you must already know what is inside
if you think about a graph,
there is no way in which
I can give you a graph and,
and just ask you, OK, please show me
where is the mark of blankets
that I need to tell you of about
which node
I'm interested in right
so you must already know
what is an aside.
And when it comes to mind,
cognitive machinery,
knowing what is inside me is knowing
which are
which presumably to bring,
plus maybe stuff and environment,
then be around whatever
and if you already know that,
which you must already know in order
to find the relevant mark blankets
that intuitively
you already
know whether the mind extends or not,
and if you already know
whether it mind extends or not,
you know whether it makes sense or not.
Very simple you you piece is
known your piece of information
to be gained
by thinking about whether mind extend
or not in terms of mark or block.
And that is the key force
the first argument,
the second one which is a bit messy.
Can I just pause there
and make a comment on the first one?
OK, awesome. So
though the mark of blanket,
if only it were like
the blankets on our bed
and you could pick it up
and it was a blanket,
whether it was inside the box
or around the box or whatever that's not
really how they are defined.
It's really like a code partitioning
of internal and external states
with respect to a blanket or a blanket
with respect to some other internal
and external states.
So the blanket states
are the ones that make two other sets
of states, internal and external,
conditionally independent.
And so it's not that a node can be
even in a purely statistical sense.
So without getting into the whole,
what do they physically map onto?
A given node is not like a blanket state
or an internal state.
It's a blanket state with respect
to some other states because it's part
of this partitioning that's co
instantiated at the same moment.
So it's an excellent point where
if you know what your system of interests
internal states are,
then you can talk about
what states blanket them
with respect to some other states.
But if the question
is about the extended mind
and what are the internal states of mind,
then there's kind of this catch 22
cat in the hat scenario where if you knew
where to even focus,
you would have already sort
of addressed the question upfront.
Just to sort of unpack that
and connect it to some of the other
ways we've talked about it.
Yeah, that's agreed.
I'm talking
the key word
you said and that I forgot to set
is the system you're interested in
why I wanted you
to focus on this right now
because deep extended mind stuff
is supposed to be hyper realistic.
Dude is not that.
I mean we can treat pen and paper as if
they were a form of external memory
that is something you can do
but is not a claim that interests me.
Clark Minnery.
The claim is that that it interests me.
Clark, I'm sorry.
Is that pen and paper really are
with the capital r e on of our
we are a piece of memory
in the external war, right?
They are memory in the same sense
in which
parts of your neural activation or
memory system
or memory that is your relevant claim.
So there is nothing observer dependent
or interest dependent is
really a part of core metaphysics about
how do you ward
actually is independently
about what you know about it.
So that's the point
that I should probably have made sooner.
Well, you made it in the paper
with the direction
of identification
runs from target variables to mark blank.
It's not the other way around.
So yeah. Great. Yeah.
So that's the first argument.
The second one is very modern
and also very
dependent on the how the eaters
were on the extended mind
and mark of blanket develop.
But the point is basically this
that from the very beginning
that would be probably who
weighs 2016 people,
the self evidencing brain, the
D message.
Look, there are many possible blankets
and we have somehow to choose one
that sort of message
get got through d d searcher
and doing which Yahoo!
Who we and others try to
single out these super special blankets
among the many possible ways
to look at south of it
dancing in the long run
about
keeping your
keeping yourself close to your set
point in the long run
and their idea as I understood it
was to say that
while the machinery of the mind
is identical to the machinery
that keeps your self
near your set point in the long run
and that sounds persuasive
from a free energy principle perspective,
but is not super earthly.
You're not very into the free energy
principle because there is a lot of stuff
that keep us alive
and kicking in the long run our liver,
our guts, our kidneys
and pretty much function.
None of those organs does
thinking in and intelligible sense.
And so did you already hear that?
Probably is never actually stated in
the paper
is that we are confusing
cognizant in some broad
and fuzzy sense with staying alive
I mean, I've nothing
against the claim that living things
tend to be organized work
tend to behave intelligent plant
do behave intelligently
even if there is
nobody says behave intelligently.
But I'm not so sure
about equating the two.
And that would be probably
my second point.
OK, let's.
Stay on this
because that's also a great point. So
if not one in the same as staying alive,
what other perspectives on cognition
might there be like?
What is thinking
other than staying alive?
Or what is it that, for example,
the neurons in the glia are doing
that the cartilage
in the knee is not doing
well?
Pretty much such a processing information
would be a distant dancer.
You take DNA
or at least sensory information.
So that
that's the question
I'm struggling with right now.
And my sense would be this,
that we have a big problem because
not because we don't have
a definition of cognition,
but because we have to manage
this edition of cognition.
We have too many research programs
telling us what cognition is.
So you have
classic cognitive science.
What is the connection?
Well, simple manipulation when you go
with the connection is what is cognition?
Well, that transformation,
some symbolic computation,
then you have an act to this.
What is cognition?
MM says meeting
autonomy, ERG, ecological psychologist.
What is cognition?
Well, interacting skill
we have affordances
and so on and so forth.
And my big problem is that
no one here is clearly wrong.
No one is obviously dead wrong.
And that thing
clearly cannot be conditioned
and so what I think I would
suggest is a sort of pluralism
about cognition.
Ignition is not a single thing,
is not like dancing what is dancing?
Well, moving your arms.
Yes, sometimes, but sometimes dancing
might even be seen
still in a certain piece of art.
There might be some regimented
still as a part of dance,
and that would be the knowledge.
So something that gets done
in a variety of ways,
none of which
prima fashion
seems to apply to kidneys, livers, flows,
and that sort of things.
If I can layer if I know one more sort of
and or there's the
experience and the phenomenology of us
as ourselves and as people.
And then there's sort of the behaviorism
or at the very least
animal behavioral sciences
or just behavioral studies in general,
which is like from the outside
looking at a system.
And so there's this gap between like us
doing the thinking about cognition
and the experience of that,
thinking about cognition,
and then the question about
recognizing cognition in other people,
in children, in non-humans, et cetera.
And so like, I really like that
how you like there's the symbol,
the sub symbolic and active
and then no one disagrees.
No one is saying that bacteria
make bad decisions.
On the whole. They're here, aren't they?
And no one's saying like a tree doesn't
have a metabolic coupling with a fungus,
and no one's saying that
the fungus doesn't diffuse signals.
But then the aspects of these systems
that people focus their regime
of attention on and where they choose
to start their talks
and what they decide to talk about
and what experiments
they design, that frames the discussion
about cognition.
That's a wonderful way to put it.
And I'm a bit sad
because the paper about cognition
has already been submitted
if I hadn't submitted it already,
I would have stolen the framing part
because it's wonderfully set up.
That said, yeah, so
there are two things
I'd like to say about that.
So the first lining is
no one really disagrees.
I'm not sure I think that
there is some genuine disagreement.
So hard core ecological psychologists,
I believe
and feel free to correct me
if there are any
ecological psychologists really think
that clinician is interacting.
We have affordances, full stop
and that there is no simple manipulation
going on in the background.
And I do classic cognitive ist.
I think redesigning that, recognizing
just these manipulate,
manipulating symbols in the background.
So there are genuine disagreements
if what I'm
not super sure about
is whether those disagreements
are solvable in the sense
that you can provide a master argument
or even master experiments
from which you can just read off
or the ecological psychologist
was wrong all along the Disney
classic community.
This was right
I think that the best we can
do is accept some form of pluralism
about what cognition is.
And perhaps but I'm not super sure
we might have to accept that
there may be things
that are neither determinedly cognitive
or determinately, not cognitive
I mean,
plants
do behave to cope with their environment.
Well,
I'm not entirely comfortable about saying
that there are cooking risers
in the exact same sense
in which I am actually nicer.
Maybe it's just because their behavior is
or is not always compared to mine.
Maybe it's because they have certain
core cultural prejudices,
which I mean, they exist and the
core calling something recognizer.
Yes, influenced by your prejudices.
You go back to the early analytic
philosopher,
know what boats
animals think and knowledge.
They know that someone
for someone to have that position. So
so there is that.
But it's not super photons
but the big message would probably be
this foot center.
There might be something
something of a gray area
between thinking with symbols,
truly cognitive and being a rock earlier,
not coming to the sort of degree area
in which you have intelligence,
coping with the environment,
coping with the environment.
Well, adaptability, flexibility,
but still
not be really sure about
whether there is some cognition
with the capital C going off
and just the first thing.
Then you also mentioned
folly about consciousness, but
I'm very scared about that stuff.
OK, so
another interesting piece
as evidenced by the the
thing about what to say carefully,
don't want to say
that it's a lane
we could veer off into, but.
Right, that is a more purely
philosophical discussion, whereas
neurobehavioral studies and cognitive
science frames itself as science.
And in science usually
we think about like unique explanations,
predictions, the ability to design
and control and perturb systems.
So is this science?
What kind of science?
What are we looking for here
in a cognitive model?
And how do we resolve or accommodate
this tension between like unique
explanations and predictions,
which is the bedrock of one type
of science with the call for pluralism
that you just made.
I think that the answer here is
do not
in the sense that the call for pluralism
is not a very
not a cool
cognitive science is splintered.
You have everyone
doing its own thing in its own lab.
There is cooperation
in this sense.
That's
I mean,
did you various research
groups are not entirely
isolated is not the case
that people working on neuro neurons
know nothing about connections
or classical
or computational
is more with a very subtle communication.
But on the face of it, what I see
as a philosopher looking at science,
it is a splinter room
of cognitive science
enterprise in a variety of groups,
each with its own peculiar research
tradition.
And I think that that is basically fine.
But if no one has a strong call
or a strong argument
or a strong model, that's
does what Newton did for
physics and unifies
everything under a single banner.
Plurality is fine.
So there is
no call is more or something like, Well,
that's reality.
Let's try to light.
I'm on board with that.
But with this banner,
what shape would it be
or how would we know it when we saw it?
I have no clue.
We probably just
would just know it when we saw it
in the sense that we would see
a research tradition start into
absorb
all others
we would probably see people
trying to demonstrate us
that there is a real
and significant equivalence
between our
powerful research tradition,
uniform research tradition,
and all the others,
and probably
the winning research tradition.
The one that really got
cognition, really got thinking,
would be able to make
some novel prediction that
no one else was able to meet.
And that would be probably
a strong marker that
that's the way to go.
If the implicit question is, do
I think that the free energy principle
is that sort of research tradition?
I'm not sure it's a
and my answer
would probably be qualified. No,
because we do not have right now
proof that is unifying as it wants to be.
It makes big unifying claims
and it might be good in the sense
that they may fall circle operation
at the very least.
So you have at least
a pragmatic advantage
whether it succeed in unifying
and it wants to
unify is still an open question.
And absolutely appropriate thing to do
is to, for me
at least, to wait and see for others
perhaps since, to pick up your tools
and try to unify it and show it,
I think really is your right thing or
just argue
against even negative arguments.
Are you right?
Non-action is an action
that's true in world knowledge traditions
and also in Bayesian statistics.
Like it can be useful to wait
to gather more information
I wanted to return to what you said
earlier
about you need some boundaries
and a lot of this discussion, of course,
it's like extended.
How extended, what is extending
and what are we looking for
with a boundary model
in the FSP and active world?
Certainly we talk a lot about different
kinds of blankets and Bayesian graphs
and things like that, but those are not
the only ways to think about boundaries.
So just wanted to learn about
what are some other ways
of thinking about
boundaries,
cognitive boundaries of different kinds
and what are you looking
for in a boundary model?
Not sure about how to answer. So
my understanding is that Markov blankets
enter into debates
as a sort of tool to wonder,
finally understand
what the boundaries of demand are
but our or no order
big alternative is not.
First, something started by Chalmers
about action and perception
in treaties, boundaries of the mind.
But what I think he had in mind
when I said that was
something like, No,
our intuitive image of your mind
is that of something that is please
between perception and action.
Something like we are intuitively
predisposed to set that something like
the classical cognitive sandwiches
we encounter in work,
the reception and action
and so
I'm not really sure whether
that sort of boundary would be a boundary
in the sense in which a block gets
would like to be boundaries.
Or are you just to play the role
of a boundary in the sense of something
that's individual, it's a single system
and tells it apart from anything else,
the problem,
I think for the extended mind
and the need for a boundary
is a need fueled by the strongest ire.
Not to say that everything counts
as a cog
in the cognitive machinery.
Why? Well, because if everything counts
as a cognitive cognitive machinery,
then we claim
that pen and paper used to do most counts
is not a big play.
It doesn't add much rights
in order to or a claim.
Well, it is part of the cognitive system
to be meaningful to being.
So there must be things that are not part
of the cognitive system.
Otherwise,
I mean, you are just claiming, well,
there is this thing which is exactly
identical to any other thing,
not suffering form.
In the paper.
You you were threading together
this question of short
and long term features of cognition,
like in the instantaneous action
perception,
cognitive behavioral timescale,
and then the quote in the long run
where a lot of the arguments
rest like it reduces
surprise in the long run,
or on average in the long run.
And then you talked about like
jumping into it,
it would force one to carry
an inordinate amount of stuff
as a cog in someone's thinking machinery,
jumping into ponds of water
while on fire or shooting at a tiger
to avoid becoming the tiger spinner.
Both contribute to one's prolonged
occupation of one's phenotypic states,
but neither ponds of water
nor guns and bullets
can be properly counted as cogs
in the thinking machinery.
And I can totally see how one type
of extended
mind perspective would say like,
yes, the boundaries
of the cognitive system are just so
and they're so flexible
that whatever it is in the situation
that enables the cognition to happen
is the cognitive system
at which point
the lines are extremely blurred.
With just the system as it is,
it's like a pan.
Cognitive is two perspective,
and that ends up,
at least from a Bayesian perspective,
not being informative
because we no longer reduce our surprise
by learning about anything
and we've sort of deflated
cognition away.
So where does that sit with you?
Is that a goal?
Like what are we looking for
in delineating cognitive systems
from each other?
Do we prefer pain, cognitive ism
do we prefer anti pain cognitive ism,
or do we want something
in between where like humans are special
or linguistic entities or special.
So I think
that cognitive is
and should be avoided in general.
If you have punished something as a
your own bed road,
probably done a better role
because if everything counters X,
there is nothing gained
about from calling things X's.
No one is puzzled by things in general.
I think.
So that's the first point Corgan found.
Cognitive dissonance should be avoided
what I think is a disease are awesome
and it would be nice
to have something balanced
in between
individualism and dignity.
I think a feeling, intuition
that sometimes interacting with stuff,
at least AIDS cognition
in a very substantial way.
So I think that
go through desiderata
would be to have a bubble around
individual pre theoretically understood
many would disagree,
many would be comfortable
with group voting and with group lines.
I think that is a minority view.
But maybe they're right. I mean the
being right or wrong is not a question.
It's not a matter of numbers
but still to friendly.
I wouldn't follow the minority in
so I would keep that option
in the theoretical horizon but not use it
to orient to research right now.
So what I would do
is to have sort of a bubble around
biological individuals and 40 timescale.
I think that
the right thing to do again
just to frame things and get them started
is to focus on short timescales.
We hyper long evolutionary time scale
is not something
that captures our go
to intuitive sense of cognition.
And when you start creating a debate,
you start from more
go to intuitive negative standpoint,
so my sympathy is for short timescale
for here and now.
It's very
funny like you mentioned, you know, it's
not a vote.
A small group of people could be correct
and a larger group could be incorrect.
Yet people often
think about voting as group cognition,
yet cognition isn't a vote.
So that's kind of an interesting tension
there
let me ask about Section five.
So it's is vehicle
external ism conditioned over market
like it's possible
and you said, I want to argue that
resorting to Markel blankets
to settle the debate over
vehicle external ism leads us to sidestep
the whole debate in a very real sense.
Making vehicle internal ism.
Vacuously true.
So just for like a little context,
what is vehicle external ism?
An internal ism like what
is the distinguishing features of these
concepts?
Why are people interested in this debate?
And like what does it matter
for talking about cognitive systems?
OK, so externally
ism and journalism are things
that happen everywhere in philosophy
and here we go to with vehicle variety,
which is internally the more externally
ism about the cost
and the thinking machinery
about the material stuff that doesn't sit
and you
you need to have a boundary in mind
to say internal and external
and the go to boundaries
just get basically the key
and often need biological
individual folks interested
in journalism would be inside the skin.
So cognition journalism or journalism
is that the machinery of thought
which is inside your skin
or more precisely inside your cranium
externally that means at least
some sense of that machinery
are outside in pen and paper
or cell phones, whatever you want
but notice
here we have an intuitive boundary
which is distinct
if you always mark of blankets
I think you end up in a dilemma
because
you either
start with some intuitive mark up
blankets, see,
and the skin use it
to define internal and external
and then you might disfigured forward
or something external
to that blanket counts
as part of the system
or you can do what again
natural power thing did, which is well,
first
I find the mark of a blanket of dots.
Then you do your real one,
the mark of blanket with the capital M,
and then use that blanket to define
what is internal and what is external
and if you do that, clearly
everything that matters is internal
by how you have defined internal
which is do you want more?
On the other hand, you start with the
standard intuitive
distinction
between internal and external,
and then try to find a mark of blanket,
which is fine, but then you mark
a blanket does no longer distinguish
between internal
and external or
there is a tension.
There are two senses of internal
and you need to disentangle the intuitive
one and DeMarco blanket
relative to the real mark of microphones.
And that is not what seems to be going on
in the literature right
so basically
that is my problem,
which is a dual philosophical approach,
I think is a purely philosophical,
not still
my concerns were philosophical.
So it got
fair enough.
Is that what you were referring to
when you said,
I doubt such a redefinition of internal
ism would
by the internal assert something more
than a purely verbal victory?
Yes, that's exactly the point.
I mean,
the internal the vehicle internal is one
at the end of the day
to say something like this,
thinking happens in debate
or close to it.
If you go on, DeMarco
Blanket Boss is defined
internally in terms of a Michael Blanket
and then discover that DeMarco Block
contains key brain, but
also the spinal cord, but also my hands,
but also Cannon pepper bottles myself
and so on and so forth.
You can say, well, all that stuff is
internal, also internal.
This is true.
But I mean,
that's a verb for victory.
That is not one what you wanted
to see at the beginning, right?
That is a form of external ism
that gets passed,
as in journalism, because of how
you have defined your terms
and noticed that
even if you go with that definition
of internal ism, then there would be
still the super internal lists
that say No, no, no.
The real internal thing that does
the thinking is just the brain
and externally, internally stored lots
internally that say, no, no, no, no,
it's your brain
plus other internal stuff within that
Mark applied
so the problem wouldn't be close.
You would still have a clash about
Sarah Brady there ever was.
Did you up people that instead it's
just your brain or your brain
and spinal cord and people
that that like external stuff
doing part of the thinking.
It makes me think of
like a thought experiment,
kind of like a tracer.
So like a radioactive tracer
might be injected in a blood vessel.
Then you can see where it flows or like a
a metabolic label
might be given to a cell
and then you can see
how it gets metabolized. So
the tracer let's just say we're following
like we're going to pluck
one of the strings and trace the impact
of like shining light on the retina.
Initially
it follows like nervous system paths.
But then let's say that light pattern
induces the system to pick up that phone
and reload a website so now that tracer
is spreading everywhere.
It's calling servers
in different parts of the world.
And it's like community.